ce qui a marqué durant ce conseil c'est
aussi l'insulte xénophobe sale portugais
qui est revenu dans les débats dès le
début plusieurs élus ont pris la parole
pour dénoncer des propos inacceptables
voire même demandé à frédéric-augis de
démissionner de son poste de président
de la métropole Cédric de Oliveira s'est
aussi exprimé publiquement pour la
première fois depuis le début de cette
affaire une prise de parole applaudi par
la plupart des élus présents Léa Turquie
était sur place
la parole c'est finalement libérée il y
a plusieurs semaines frédéric-augis
président de la métropole insulté Cédric
des Oliveira l'un de ses vice-présidents
de salles portugais des propos racistes
condamnés par plusieurs conseillers ce
lundi soir à tour de rôle Patrick
Lefrançois Benoît pierre et enfin Régis
salique ces propos sont tout bonnement
insupportables et intolérable je ne me
sens plus représentée par Frédéric Augis
je ne sais pas qui le peut encore
aujourd'hui
et je lui demande simplement de prendre
ses responsabilités vous devez
aujourd'hui je crois tirer les
conséquences de cette injure à caractère
raciste qui nous offre tous républicains
que nous sommes autour de cette table
comment on peut continuer à fonctionner
dans une ambiance ou l'insulte à
caractère raciste et un moyen
d'expression pour moi c'est inadmissible
après ces soutiens pour la première fois
le concerné Cédric des Oliveira s'est
exprimée en public au sujet de cette
affaire il s'explique profondément
blessé lui et sa famille par les propos
du président de la métropole
j'ai opté pour la voie de
l’avertissement à travers un courrier
plutôt qu'une carte déposée directement
parce que je ne souhaitais pas
hystériser un débat déjà très vif
et bien c'est avec courage chers
collègues ce soir que je réaffirme qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir au sein du Conseil
métropolitain les insultes ou quelconque
ma tête danse entre élus une prise de
parole applaudi par de nombreux
conseillers et les regards se tournent
vers Frédéric cogis
je ne suis pas exprimé car j'ai eu tort
de prononcer cette phrase je ne pense
pas et qui représentent pas mes valeurs
j'ai bien sûr exprimé mes excuses pas
écrit et par votre téléphonique depuis
Cédric dans les jours qui ont suivi une
réponse brève car le président de Tours
métropole Val de Loire ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer plus largement avant son
audition devant la justice pour rappel
une plainte a été déposée à son encontre
par SOS Racisme pour un Jura caractère
racial